tel un cortège qui a donc été rejoints
par les gilets jaunes qui avaient
organisé ce matin une manifestation ils
ont rejoint ce cortège et il ya
notamment jérôme rodriguez que nous
avons pu interroger évidemment les
violences policières c'est un thème qui
lui est cher parce qu'il en a lui-même
été la victime je vous propose d'écouter
donc jérôme rodrigues au vu des
perspectives aujourd'hui par rapport au
confinement aux lois liberticides qui
lui sont imposées on s'est compliqué de
se regrouper à ces passivement
je pense qu'il sera important
aujourd'hui de répondre à l'appel du 1er
mai un appel qui existe depuis de
longues années de mai voir se regrouper
avec l'ensemble des citoyens on perd ce
jour-là de tous les groupes d'action
qu'ils soient syndicales politiques
associatifs de pouvoir descendre puis ce
qu'on l'aimait et et montrer notre force
et notre mécontentement à l'ensemble du
gouvernement
on se recoupent rend l'ensemble des
français et pourquoi pas rejoindre le
plus beau romain france celui des champs
elysées euros pour la mise au travail
pour ça